la cocaïne est présente tout le temps le
soir surtout et puis après le lendemain
pour pallier à la fatigue quoi pour
tenir encore plus
Lolita scène bonsoir
alors le
vous n'étiez encore qu'une jeune fille
sage lorsque vous avez signifié votre
première rail de cocaïne avec des
copines peu de temps après vous montez à
Paris vous travaillez dans la pub puis
dans l'événementiel la coq va alors
prendre une place centrale dans votre
métier dans vos relations dans vos
amours la coque va prendre le contrôle
de votre vie pendant 5 ans cette
histoire vous leur racontez dans un
livre intitulé C'est la face noire de la
blanche publié chez Robert Laffont et à
20h dans Salut les Terriens
[Musique]
Lolita vous étiez le 23 avril
1987 à Montpellier permet de Saint mère
secrétaire médicale au départ pendant
votre scolarité vous êtes une petite
fille sage bien élevée danse classique
patinage artistique aussi doué en
sciences quand l'être bref un esprit
saint dans un corps sain et puis au
lycée l'ambiance commence à changer un
peu autour de vous les filles veulent
toutes ressembler à Kate Moss c'est ça
oui c'est ça
quand vous arrivez en terminale vous
n'avez jamais fumé et vous ne buvez pas
après votre bac S vous choisissez une
classe préparatoire en cinéma vous
voulez intégrer l'école Louis Lumière à
Paris et c'est là que votre vie va
basculer un jour
vous n'avez pas encore 19 ans vous
prenez un verre avec vos copines un mec
dit je vais faire des courses il revient
avec un petit bloc de cocaïne il
commence à le briser avec sa carte de
crédit il fait des lignes et quand votre
tour arrive en fait l'idée de refuser
nous vient même pas à l'esprit quoi
résultat vous dites toutes mes
appréhensions s'éclipse pour laisser
place au doux et à l'agréable
avec la première fois c'est pas mauvais
c'est après que c'est dur complètement
après votre classe préparatoire vous
obtenez un stage dans une agence de pubs
à Paris vous quittez la province vous
montez à Paris et là voilà vous avez ce
rêve qu'on a tous eu à une époque
j'espère devenir chic comme ces femmes
qui flammes naturelles juché sur 10 cm
de talon et puis j'étais une petite
jeune et c'est vrai que j'avais cette
représentation toute faite j'avais
vraiment envie de d'appartenir à la
grande classe de devenir une grande et
de
des rêves de jeunes filles au début vous
vous ennuyez terriblement à Paris
jusqu'au jour où parvenez à vous faire
inviter dans une soirée aux Invalides en
l'appartement est top et là vous dites
chaque fille semble sortir d'un magazine
vous finissez par vous retrouver dans
une chambre à l'abri des convives avec
un mec donc miroir sachez blanc vos yeux
s'illuminent le mec vous fait des lignes
de couple et là vous embrassez et vous
écrivez j'ai envie de l'épouser je veux
qu'il m'embrasse toute ma vie
oui
et on a l'impression d'être beau et on a
l'impression que la personne en face de
soi est belle aussi alors que
sincèrement peut-être que c'était une
personne tout à fait ordinaire je me
souviens vous quittez la pub pour
l'événementiel et là c'est encore pire
parce que effectivement vernissage dîner
soirée la cocaïne s'intègre parfaitement
à cette nouvelle vie et vous raconter
qu'à l'agence où vous travaillez en fin
de journée avant de sortir tout le monde
tape des lignes de coq sur le bureau
quoi je pense qu'une bouteille de whisky
aurait été plus inappropriée
et un soir dans un bar du troisième
arrondissement vous rencontrez celui que
vous appellerez bientôt l'homme de ma
vie il a 30 ans et roule à moto une
bonne ville il vit dans un grand loft et
comme vous il travaille dans le monde de
la nuit et là la vie qui commence et
rythmée par la poudre avec lui la
cocaïne est présente tout le temps le
soir surtout et puis après le lendemain
pour pallier à la fatigue quoi pour
tenir encore plus oui en fait il achète
il revend la moitié de ce qu'il a acheté
ce qui paye sa consommation donc la
coréenne n'est pas un problème d'argent
en fait c'est là et ça nous accompagne
comme la cigarette le soir où vous lui
annoncer que vous êtes enceinte et que
vous pensez vous faire avorter vous
n'arrivez pas à en parler en fait ce que
vous évitez le sujet toute la nuit en
buvant de la vodka et en se nivelant des
lignes de coke
on était perdu
notre façon de donc ouais on a on a
préféré taper la coque et boire des
chiottes de vodka au lieu de un peu
discuter de ça
mais après tout recommence comme avant
votre relation avec lui c'est ça et on
sait que quand dans un couple on est
tous les deux dans la même drogue c'est
impossible de s'en sortir on va vers le
fond à deux quoi
alors après un an de relation c'est la
séparation vous êtes dévasté pendant des
semaines
jusqu'au jour vous décidez de reprendre
le fil de votre vie et le fil de votre
vie c'est les sorties l'alcool et la
coke rien ne vous sert de leçon
alors évidemment vous allez prendre
d'argent
ou posez-nous pour un vinyle et vous
dites la cocaïne me rend indifférente à
ma pudeur on est mené par la poudre en
fait c'est vrai qu'on a plus aucune
pudeur et qu'on vient voilà
alors là dans un moment de lucidité vous
décidez de quitter Paris pour aller vous
reposer dans le sud chez vos parents
évidemment ils ont du mal à reconnaître
la petite fille sage qu'ils a quittés
quelques temps auparavant vous avez des
sautes d'humeur vous criez enfin vous
êtes assez insupportable quand même
mais bon une fois que vous êtes retourné
dans le midi chez vos parents quelques
semaines plus tard vous avez à nouveau
le téléphone d'un dealer régulier et
quand vous rejoignez votre chambre
d'enfant un petit matin vous avez la
tête à l'envers alors votre physique se
dégrade en fait vos dons sont striés de
noir vos ongles sont cassants vous êtes
ultra maigre vous descendez à 46 kg
quand même vous avez l'impression d'être
une de ces mannequines qu'on voit dans
les magazines
artistes aussi un peu énervé tout le
temps
les pilules les cacher la cortisone
jusqu'au jour fait une overdose de
kétamine
là vous réveillez quand même 20 heures
plus tard en vomissant de la bile vous
avez vu la mort
vos parents quoi votre père il est
toubib votre mère elle est assistante
médicale ivoirien non on pense
simplement que c'est ma nature c'est ma
façon d'être on va pas penser que je me
drogue il y a que les autres qui font ça
alors vous remontez à Paris
vous replongez dans la coke et ça me
fait un bien fou le flash m'électrise la
tête
parce qu'il faut dire aux gens quand
même on parle toujours de l'addiction à
l'héroïne qui est gravissime mais la
cocaïne il y a une dépendance
psychologique qui est très forte aussi
faut pas croire que la cocaïne c'est une
drogue uniquement récréative c'est
quelque chose de très dangereux quand on
lit votre livre on le voit je vous le
dire quand même aux gens qui nous
regardent alors là la dépendance
psychologique devient terrible
vous comprenez dans les taxis sur la
petite
tablette à l'arrière ou à l'hôtel avec
des amendes d'un soir
vous êtes assez légère quand même
à ce moment là ouais on se rend pas
compte quoi on y avait tellement de
soirées tellement de nuit de jour on
voit plus vraiment léger les différences
entre les arts et on ne voit plus les
amants non plus qui a dans les jusqu'au
jour où vous devenez aveugle là vous
avez une espèce d'alu effrayant vous
dites là ça devient grave quand même un
moment vous avez peur là ça m'est arrivé
deux fois mais je commençais à réaliser
quelques cocaïne avait quand même en
danger voilà hein
vous allez sur Google et vous tapez aide
pour arrêter la cocaïne bon mais le
week-end suivant vous craquez alors là
c'est terrible pourquoi s'infliger une
telle douleur après tout je me fais du
mal pour rien je pourrais ralentir et en
prendre de temps en temps en fait vous
replongez pendant un an
ensuite il vous faudra six mois pour
être vraiment sevré mais bon quand même
c'est là que vous ouvrez votre blog qui
s'appelle moi Juliette F vous recevez
des milliers de mails de gens qui vous
demandent des conseils comment je peux
arrêter comment je peux me sortir de
cette enfer parce que c'est un enfer il
faut le dire aux gens
ça fera deux ans en juin que vous avez
arrêté
vous y pensez des fois
ça me revient mais il suffit de penser à
ce trou noir de descente les jours
perdus tout ça pour ne pas la prendre la
trace est-ce que de temps en temps vous
tapez une ligne ou pas du tout bravo
[Applaudissements]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
inarritube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu